yeah hello and welcome to yet another
session of some live blitz they got
clearing quick quite quite quickly danke
shots my opponent in Poland
[Music]
no sky no name okay so let's get started
it's just a good moment to do this video
I just have like roughly an hour and
it's a good one to do in that time frame
I also want to do a different video try
a video soon probably I would do that to
be released
tomorrow that will be about
solving some
exercises
really know how long that will take and
so it's a bit of a new thing with the
set up here like in OBS and so on their
form I would do this tomorrow and when
I'm then I'm a little bit more flexible
so an interesting line yet black tried
to wait and successfully but I take and
then he probably wants to go if I if I
assume he didn't do that now one point
was that he delayed knight c6 so that we
don't get this typical Greenfeld
scenario where white can take on c6 so
this is interesting I'm curious now what
he's going to do probably black will
take on c4 that's the move that looks
like the most natural choice no this is
also a natural choice no nothing wrong
about this one now interesting I can go
to f3 or - see - I think f3 and now yeah
I guess d4 even though you could make an
argument about 95 that doesn't look
like a terrible idea either it's a bit
uncommon
put the knight here near but why not if
he takes on c4 I'm I'm happy to take on
c4 with the night and the night is not
so insecure it doesn't have many squares
you know this is why I was hesitating
for a moment but I think I can always
take on d5 and basicly i guaranteed the
c4 scram
yeah I have tea by the way it's a tea
session but the tea is not yet ready
still have it in here it needs to sit
for a moment it's probably not the right
word for that
I know what the English word is
that you have to wait for the tea to be
ready
interesting now mmm yeah I guess I'll
just take
I want to have to see Foursquare so not
can't happen to my night yeah I wonder
how he will recapture actually to take
with the Queen YUM it makes quite a bit
of sense however now if I take yes to
take with the bishop more or less and
now Knight c3 looks like a little bit of
an awkward moment because how does he
actually handle this I'm threatening to
take on d5 and on e4 and yeah this is
not really helping I mean I'm just
winning a pawn here right
and he resigned what do I actually win
even more I win a pawn I mean what is to
show I can't take this this this and we
need for with the great position yeah
that was a bit a bit weird
which I think here I'm fine anyway after
95 I think the black center is a little
bit loose so yeah the engine gives white
0.5 something like that is probably fair
now you came
which I still have to wait a moment for
the team
it's actually a good way to do this you
had to set it up here just and it needs
some minutes and I mean I see how long
the recording is is on film and this is
my tee time oh I have a dedicated one
okey kitchen kitchen clock which still
yeah no no no I get again been to be us
okay
you
I'm mixing here between the Rogozin
Deebo go the two openings that I've
covered in books or online courses 193
and God can take it
and somehow nights is six what I'm
remembering but not the line that has
studied in much detail I think somehow
nights is six is right
they put some pressure on deform and why
doesn't have that easier job too
Regained a pawn
happy to gain the bishop am
you
always feels like I've already
accomplished something what
what to beep d5
who even thinks about stuff like that
I take g5 he takes his six I mean this
is probably not so bad but
you
[Music]
yeah I don't really see a problem with
this this is looking fine we'll take f6
screen takes 95 26 and this is
definitely fine for black
I'm still upon up I have Bishop e6
coming with the tempo
and I don't see anything special here
that he can do
you
yeah now we should be six I think
check the night
that was the idea
you
you
YUM
yeah I still try to keep this pawn so
get the Queen back
ready for night ex-queen chicks
Queen a for Quincy to who
yeah that is true I can't play b5 I mean
and why not let's do it
it really has to show me how he's
getting this back
be three I can take a three
and once I get drunk out of the diagonal
the weakening is not that important
anyway
you
you know so let's get the rook out of
this diagonal
there is still no
III because a3 is hanging
you
YUM so now this is a bit more of a
concern but as I can just take
I did still it's still fairly dry of
course but I can maybe try to go to f6
and attack his pawns
they are on on dark squares and not so
easily defended maybe nights yeah
exactly 94
you
okay but the point is pretty weak
if he goes d5 his own bishops dead that
cannot be the right way to do it how it
still plays it
yeah but why am I not just winning the
whole Queen side here
or at least be to which is the most
important so okay I take this pawn he
checks me
hmm
you
it also takes is seven
you
you
can also check out in one
first
you
yeah I got a couple of good options
really umm g6 is the most solid one
simply so that I have g7 and he cannot
take a 6 because Queen e1 bishop divorce
is killing
and my next move okay this is winning
there's no way to come here to
you
must move Queen checks of to okay I'm
doing rematch there
I just got a message yeah I have to
leave
point because I'm
actually
driving to
a friend of mine who has this mail-order
chess book mail-order business
and I'm going to sign my book I'm copies
that he has ordered or his business and
I will give you this information also on
my channel so if you want signed copies
of my book you can order them directly
from him here's all the logistics setup
for sending the books out I did this
with my first book myself and this was
yeah on the one hand it was fun yeah I
get to here I go to the post office
everyday with books and getting messages
from people all over the world that got
the book but it was also really really
it was lots of work and in particular
there were problems with with some of
the some of the shipping with the more
exotic location so I ultimately with
keep it simple efore I am
change this procedure and now my friend
is taking care of that so
he's much more used to doing this he has
a
someone to come over to his place from
them I'm not sure what it is yeah from
one of those services like DHL or
something and they pick it up and it's
just much much better organized and what
this is a huge square on d6
even playing c-5m
stop him from from
from ever going to play
see five himself
you should a three stops the b-pawn to
move
yeah I wonder I can even go h4 h5
it's a tough call because everything is
really really strong for white
I think I will play H form
and he still has a hard time to play v6
so let's go H form
you
now g5 is the idea
you
yeah both captures look strong I'm going
to I'm going to take with this this is
stronger because this this must be
winning if that's not winning something
is really wrong with chess I'm attacking
with everything
you know I you just resigned I have
rookie six coming and it's just going to
be devastating we can play two games I
think more than
who games as too much
clever kinks okay yeah I probably will
make us slower short a session of this
because as mentioned I got to drive to
my friend there to sign the books it was
actually expected only to happen later
but it seems that he has gotten
the shipment early amps um
you
yeah this is a very well-known variation
out of the H Hawk line that I have
played a lot
and this was also the line featured and
my best ever winning over the board
chest
Ince Grandmaster Mikhailovich and one
point number five in the world not at
the time when I played him he was a
little bit
past his prime already but just so the
2600 GM at the time
it was the line that featured in this
game unfortunately I have lost the
scoresheet
and I cannot quite repre deuce the game
it's more than 20 years ago
I know how it roughly went but it's not
the precise Morris does this looks into
his estrus for black and threatening
night age six now I mean he has spent
like 15 seconds effectively and is
completely lost
Knight age 6 is devastating pawn takes
pawn takes chick and look at this
yeah it would still work yeah night age
six but
it will not meet him
you know it's still good enough I just
wonder if I have something better
[Music]
only not as something like 94 will win
but
but okay let's do this
you
take this
and now Queenie six is almost made
almost
oh let's say I go before and he cannot
move the night it's not bad
five also looks pretty good
five is also completely devastating
you
waiting to take on g6 but also f6 it's
just far too much yeah there was an
opening catastrophe really a disaster
okay new opponent
yeah I'm on the way to 2600 medium
would be nice it would be a record I
think this is the highest rating
anyway that I had here on blitz
this is the line that I recommended in
my
2015 book new zoo in pavilion
admittedly
gotten quite a huge chunk of my
recommendations at some
written five years ago and
I've in particular I've written so much
since and analyzed so much that I
sometimes have problems to remember
I mean this is the gruffly theory of
course but erm
[Music]
not to 100% certain about things
see
ship will go here anyway so I can do
this now
now how to do this Nye g6 maybe it does
not have such a great square to go to
which should be three gets immediately
taken
so
maybe I can annoy me
with Jim
tonight takes F to being a threat
maybe g5 oftentimes black can play for
King side attack in descendants
variation because I have many pieces
actually there the Knights the bishop is
pointing and why does focus more on
Queen side play it's got everything here
in this vicinity and this is sometimes
actually read Ange Rose Knight xf2
already was a threat so here we go each
porn
which team
you
can we already strike this is actually a
stupid thing to ask yourself because at
the end of the day I will play this move
anyway so let's do this in a blitz game
this is certainly a playable option
White's king is open and I'm not certain
it might even be a good one even in a
even a classical kind of time control
game because yeah look at White's King
this cannot be called save this move I
didn't even consider actually
didn't consider this at all so I can
take on d4 also
click into g5
kay
each one is not quite clear how I'm
winning then
[Music]
you
it's - he will probably go to h1
you
really all that clear I don't
mind him taking the rook actually this
is not really a thing
you
adding naturally
would absolutely like to cut him off
- off them
Oh at the end I need Bishop f3 in the
sister
the Moors
I don't see how
I could get em Bishop f3
but Teague and this one
at Rennes Bishop f3 but he can play
queen d3 for example
probably do it
you know you can go queen d3
you
and I don't think I've got enough then
now 23s is basically saving him I think
I can take a 1 though this is not
totally clear
interesting
you pay a bishop a three wins winsett's
is made but
yeah maybe it is not 100% clear at least
not obvious okay
[Music]
you
you
yeah I have to make a move
I wasn't certain because there also was
rookie to
one move earlier
maybe this would have been stronger
now that was stronger for schwa
Shuang
No okay
I just have to try that disk
and take next on f2
just one check would do it
you can even play ruku G to wear because
G 1 and F 1 is covered
it's lucky
you
you
you
ah
[Music]
you
yeah that was not really that
well-deserved
was just attacking the King eras kitchen
think attack I'm actually fairly certain
that okay this was not sound but I
thought after which I should get
something
like didn't didn't have anything here
like
and the engine is just
merciless
merciless yeah I thought this could be
an idea but he has rook takes you for
the ideas that Knight takes Bishop f3
yeah now here I can take f2
and this is looking looking good
yeah it looks good yeah now he is just
yes defended simply and I can just share
hope
hope for the best
and this is of course completely lost
yeah but okay it's still trickier here
yeah I'm winning yeah I'm threatening
everything Knight takes Knight h4 and so
on that's already already winning from
like yeah it's tricky with seconds it's
always tough to play I've lost many
games like that okay so um what about
I'm going to go for one more game and
then
I got to leave science and books Maria
bets cote d'ivoire said probably that
the wife or relative of
the chess author bets cool off maybe
you
is going for the sharper line here with
G takes
or Bishop f6g takes
the right way to put this Bishop c2 is
interesting ah f4 now is a draw after
Queen h5 but I don't want to make a draw
97 blunders this is wrong
don't remember what I'm playing here
actually
you
I don't remember
okay now
maybe it was wrong him weenie eight I
cannot play
you
on
I have to play King h8 now I remember
remember teenage aid after player
that's stupid
you
I cannot cover the bishop as she just
takes an N place but should be three
ha idiot
of course I need an idiom
I need Bishop f7 now and this doesn't
work now
you
ass
you
it's already it's lost unfortunately I
have simply no way we will play this
it's lost
after Queen takes Shiro
it's totally lost after context always
the made on h7 I hate this kind of thing
you just forget the line
and now whites I mean she she never
needed to do anything in the game I just
gifted it away
I need this bishop f7 Queen takes stuff
yam
I just forgot it
okay so we now have to do what we have
to do in this fashion cough if you have
blundered stuff you can always count on
on you activity now you have to just try
to be tricky and try to
most problems even if you are two points
down I shouldn't blunder more oh my god
what the game
it's unfortunately is so easy to win now
for white it's tough to even pose
problems even if she would play
something super stupid she would
probably win
you
you know Bishop b3 is trading off an
important important piece that's
probably what I would do
rookie one is of course a good one
or simply attack the e4 pawn this is an
additional weakness in my position
you
unfortunately very very easy to win
[Music]
well it's not really the best way to do
it but
as I said multiple times everything wins
basically we never five now is
completely pulling the plug
No
you
you know it's increments I could resign
it I kind of want to punish myself for
being an idiot there
was impossible to repair this position
unfortunately really once once I forgot
the line things were really completely
completely over
you
yeah
you
rubbing it in like I have no I have no
good this cover check is unfortunately
true
you
you know yeah this is this is a sad game
because I just yeah I forgot the theory
okay then this whole line is basically
harmless anyway because you can draw
with f4 this is a well-known draw that
the draw is Queen age five who have
seven and white cannot get more than a
draw you see the zero here the engine
immediately recognizes the drawing
variation but of course we don't want to
draw you want to fight and the way to do
it is I think King to age eight the line
now goes Queen age five e form
Knight f4 Bishop f7 win f5 you should g8
weenie for d5 and this is a huge attack
for black this is the line that I have
in my repertoire but I just I just screw
it up
I remember it right Liam right after
that and this is a pretty cool liner now
with d5 yeah white cannot take it
because then he collapses or she
collapses on the e-file so Queen here
three has to be played and now B should
be 5 is a good move or Queen d6 both I
interesting yeah I think I had Bishop b5
g 3 d for something like that I mean
it's it's crazy
but black has fantastic compensation or
the material but I forgot it and that's
unfortunately here at the end of the
game forgetting a key a key variation
it's sometimes an issue in blitz chess
if you and get to if you face some kind
of secondary line and then you cannot
quite puzzle it together it's not so
much a problem if you have a bit of time
so okay I already explained that I have
to run so thanks a lot for watching the
video and I'll post something soon about
getting my inch book with ya with my
signature if you like thanks for
watching